[موسيقى]
على ضفاف وادي حنيفه العظيم الذي ياتي من
الشمال الغربي بمدينه الرياض من مرتفعات
جبل العارض ويمتد بمسافه مئه كيلو متر في
اتجاه الجنوب ثم ينحرف شرقا على غير عاده
الاوديه في هضبه نجد التي تتجه شمالا قامت
على هذا الوادي العظيم الذي كان في نهايات
عصر السافانا كان يجري كان دائما الجريان
قسم وجديس وجدوا قبل الف سنه قبل الميلاد
كما ذكرت عده روايات لكن النهر
ربما في وقتهم وادي حنيفه كان يمشي
ليس بقوه العصور المطيره انما اقل ودائما
الحضارات تقوم على المياه على وادي حنيفه
هذا عن يمينه وشماله من جهه الشرق ومن جهه
الغرب قامت حضارات
ذكرتها التاريخ ذكرتها المصادر التاريخيه
منذ طسم وجديس وحتى في العصور الحجريه قبل
طسم وجديس الى بني حنيفه الى وقتنا الحار
انظروا هذا الوادي اعيد تاهيله قام بذلك
امير الرياض حينها الملك سلمان عام 2010
حفظه الله ومستشاري هو ولي العهد الان عاد
والوادي كما كان يمشي
وبجانب هذا الوادي في الجنوب جنوب
الرياض جنوب حجر
حجر اليمامه قديما
بلده الحني التاريخيه التي تعتبر نموذج من
نماذج العماره وفي الحديث ان الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم عليه في حديث الرواه قال
نبئت او راى في الرؤيا
اني هاجرت من مكه الى بلد كثيره النخل
فذهب وهل الى انها هجر هجر يعني الاحساء
او اليمامه كان يعني
يوازن بين هاتين المنطقتين والمدينتين
لماذا لان هجر واليمامه فيهما مياه غزيره
وفيهما انتاج للتمر لكنه لاحقا
هاجر الى المدينه المنوره
[موسيقى]
في واد وجد فيه سلاما وطمانينه استقر
الانسان ثم زرع وحصد وبنى قريه بيوتها
حجريه هذه القريه لا نرى من جدرانها اليوم
الا مترا او اقل
انها الموصل او الفارعه قديما وتسمى اليوم
الحني في الجهه الجنوبيه من بلدتي منفوحه
والمصانع ارضا مطله على ضفاف وادي حنيفه
وعلى مرتفع منها بنيت بلده حجريه بعيدا عن
مجرى السيل قريبه من اراضي زراعيه خصمه
مازلنا في احدى البلدات القديمه جنوب
الرياض اي جنوب حجر اليمامه قديما ومع
الدكتور راشد ما اسم هذا المكان الاثري
هذه هذا المكان يقال له الحني قديما
والاشارات القديمه التاريخيه تشير الى انه
الفارعه او الموصل قديما قبل اكثر من 1200
عام هذه المنطقه الحني التي الان نجد لها
اثار ضخمه ولكنها كثيرا منها مندفنه الان
هذا احد المجسات المهمه لهذه المنطقه
لتقدم ايضا لنا صوره ما كان سابقا في هذه
في هذه في هذه الحي لماذا سميت
يعتقد الحنين هذه التسميه وردت لي ان
كونها
كونها على جهه الوادي حنيفه المطل عنها
شرقا واتت بشكل منحني يعني في زاويه معينه
من هذا الوادي
كم عمر هذا المبنى يقدر الان تقريبا من
اكثر من 1200 عام يعني البقايا التي وجدت
في هذه المنطقه تدل على انها اخرها احد
القطع العملات القديمه في سنه 127 من
الهجره فاذا بالتالي نجري الى ان هذه
المدينه اكثر من 1300 سنه على وجود تلك
العمله
التي في تلك الفتره نعم وهي بلده تابعه
لحجر اليمامه قديما ولا خارج حجر
البلدات الملحقه بحجر اليمامه قديما حجر
اليمامه هي العاصمه المركزيه لمنطقه
اليمامه وتوجد عن هذا المكان تقريبا من
الجهه الشماليه قرابه 87 كيلو مترات لكن
هذه البلدات القديمه المتصله بوادي حنيفه
وهذه هي احداها وهي تابعه لبني حنيف نعم
اي تابعه قديما لبني حنيفه وجود بني حنيفه
القديم لاستقرار من الجهات الجنوبيه من
هذا المكان يقال له الحائر القديم التي
اشار لها الشعراء ثم ناتي من الجهه الحائر
جنوبا ناتي الى الشمال فتكون هذه المنطقه
وشمال ايضا هذه المنطقه مناطق اخرى في هذه
الجهه
ماذا قال
الاعشى شاعر
اليمامه القديمه ماذا قال عن الحائر قصيده
المشهوره شاقتك من قتله اطلالها بالشط
فالوتر فالحاجه
الى مارد فقاعوا منفوحه في الحائري هذه
المنطقه بين قاع منفوحه والحائر هذه التي
نتناولها في هذه المنطقه نحن الان بينقاع
منفوحه والحائر والحائر صحيح
يعود تاريخها الى زمن قبيلتي تصم وجديس اي
عمرها نحو ثلاثه الاف عام
الحني كانت مستوطنه يقول باحثون ثريه
بعماره منازلها واسواقها وابارها على
الرغم من ان المسوحات حتى اليوم تقول ان
مستوطنه الحني في حجر اليمامه تحتل مساحه
كيلومتر مربع ونصف الا ان الابحاث التي
يطالب بها الباحثون لهذه القريه الاثريه
جنوب مدينه الرياض قد تكشف عن مفاجات
كثيره وربما تكون احداها ان حدود الحني
اوسع من ذلك بكثير
نعم هذا الان نموذج قديم المدينه حجر
اليمامه يقدم الانسان له التصور قبل 1500
سنه النظام العمراني الموجود في حجر
اليمامه هذا نظام مماثل له وانا اذكر
الحقيقه قبل عشرين سنه اكتشف احد الباحثين
الزملاء الاستاذ محمد الحمود لو الحقيقه
الفضل بعد الله عز وجل في اكتشاف ايضا هذه
المنطقه ان يتمنى ايضا ان تزاد الحقيقه
البحوث واجراء الاكتشافات عليها لكنها
الان هذا التصور القديم المباني المعماريه
الطرز المعماريه الموجوده في حجر اليمامه
العاصمه التاريخيه لمدينه الرياض هذا احد
النماذج التي ننتبه لها الحقيقه وتقدم
ايضا لنا الفكره عن البناء العمراني في
مدينه حجر اليمامه طيب
الان يا دكتور نرى هذا البناء من الحجر
حجر الجير الموجود في ظهره طويق وفي جبل
صحيح اذا البناء قوي السؤال لاحظ في
القرون اللاحقه الرياض وقبل ما تكون اسمها
الرياض يبنون بالطين فقط صحيح لماذا تحول
البناء من حجر قوي الى طين هل هو الوضع
الاقتصادي هو هذه الوضع الاقتصادي هو عامل
اساسي لا شك وايضا الانسان ابن بيئته
فاقرب الاشياء الان للاستخدامات البيئيه
نجدها ايضا الحجاره وهناك ايضا الحجاره
مهنه قديمه وايضا وردت لها في المصادر
التاريخيه هناك مهن معروفه منها مهنه ايضا
الذين يقطعون الحصى مثلا ومهن معينه يعني
هذه الجزء الان الموجود في هذه المنطقه
تقدم لنا ايضا جزء من التصور العام كما
ذكرنا المباني الموجوده في حجر اليمامه
طبعا هذه الان بعد دخول الرمال من اكثر من
20 سنه ادت ايضا الى ارتفاع النموذج هذا
احنا داخلين فيه وايضا تجد النموذج الطروز
المعماريه للبيوت القديمه وهذا احدها يعني
الان نجد فيه هنا نجد التنور القديم
التنور القديم الذي يستخدم للطعام من اكثر
من 1500 سنه هذه بقاياها الان موجوده
[موسيقى]
يعني اهم شيء في الموضوع يا دكتور الان
لما نشوف الحجر الحجر يحتاج قص صحيح صحيح
قديما لما كان الوضع الاقتصادي ليس جيد هو
الحجر موجود بكل مكان لكنه متعبه طين اسهل
صحيح صحيح يعني هنا
التنور هنا نجد ايضا هذا
نحفر التنور القديم شوف نجد التنور هذا
موجود شوف الرماد نعم هذا الرماد القديم
الذي يستخدم لايضا لاعداد الطعام ووضع
ايضا البر فيه وايضا استخدام الاكل هذه
نموذج من النماذج القديمه الموجوده في كل
منزل من منازل حجر اليمامه القديمه تقدم
لك هذا التصور وايضا هذه الفكره في قضيه
تصميم البيوت الموجوده في حجر اليمامه اذا
قصور
القصور القديمه من ايام طسم
وجديس والتي بقيت كانت مبنيه من الحجر
والليله
الى القرن الرابع الهجري صحيحي مبنيه من
الحجر وزاد البناء والاتساع في وجود
الاستقرار الحضري لقبيله بني حنيفه بني
حنيفه الاتصال ايضا الحضاري وعمق الوادي
ادى الى اتساع ايضا ونماء البلدات المحيطه
بهذا الوادي من ضمن هذه البلدات ما نحن
الان موجودين فيه
ونرى الان زي ما تشوف كثره الفخار صحيح
صحيح وجذع شجره متحجر ترى هذا مهم جدا هذا
جذع الشجره المتحجر معناته انه في مدينه
كبيره مدفونه تحتاج تنقيب وكذلك هذا
النموذج اللي انا الموجودين فيه هنا
النموذج ايضا الاماكن الاخرى المجاوره
لهذا ربما سيتم له الحفريات فيها وجدنا
اعظم من هذه باضعاف اضعاف وهذه الحقيقه
لابد ان تتجه لها الجهات ايضا مختصه
والمهتمه ايضا في التنقيب والاثار في
الجامعات او الجهات العلميه او الجهات
الحكوميه لابد الحقيقه ان ينقبون ايضا
والمزيد من الاكتشافات الحقيقه تخرج علينا
اضعاف اضعاف وتقدم لنا نموذج كما ذكرنا
الموجوده ايضا في مدينه حجر اليمامه اذا
الرياض حجر اليمامه قديما وما حولها من
بلدات التنقيب الاثري لانه تعرف مر علينا
فتره ما كان في ربما هذه الاثاره اكثر
تدمره صحيح صحيح سواء في الرياض او غير
الرياح صحيح لكن الرياض تاريخها في
التاريخ صحيح يعني شوف كثره المدققات
الادوات الحجريه شيء عجيب الزجاج نجده في
هذه المنطقه ايضا استيراد الزجاج من خارج
الجزيره العربيه نجد نماذج لهذا الزجاج
لان القوافل حجر اليمامه من اهم محطات درب
البخور الفين سنه قبل الميلاد في ناس
يقولون اقل في ناس يقولون لكن مع تسجيل
الجمل وما ذكرناه سابقا من ادله انها من
الاف السنين قبل الميلاد صحيح منذ تجين
الجمل وهي محطه من درب التجاره
على مقربه من ضفاف السيل على سفح جبلي
منخفض بنيت البيوت وفوقها على مرتفع اخر
بنيت بيوت واسواق هنا اجزاء من جدران
طويله يقال انها كانت اسوارا حول مزارع
فيها اربعه ابار عيد اليحيى كعادته يوثق
قطاعا فخاريه واخرى زجاجيه وادوات حجريه
منتشره في هذا الموقع الذي ما زال بانتظار
مزيد من التنقيب الاثري طيب يا دكتور راشد
لما صعدنا قليلا عن ضفه وادي حنيفه وجدنا
هذه الجدران
المبنيه من الحجاره هل هي تابعه للحني لا
شك كما ذكرنا يعني المنطقه هذه كالمسمى
القديم
الفارعه فالموصل المسماه الان الحنين الان
اللي احنا موجودين فيها لا شكلنا منطقه
الحقيقه اختيارها ايضا للارتفاع عن الوادي
اعطاها ميزه ولهذا كان القدماء يبحثون عن
الناحيه الامنيه في المقام الاول واستمر
هذا ايضا الى كثير من الانشاءات المدن
الان في الجزيره العربيه وغيرها لكن تقدم
الحقيقه لنا هذه المنطقه صوره جميله جدا
عن الوضع السائد الموجود حول البلدات
الموجوده حول وادي حنيفه ولهذا كان
ارتفاعها بارز وفيها المنشات ايضا
الموجوده ربما ايضا ادوات معماريه وايضا
هناك بيوت لكن الان للاسف مخفيه وتحتاج
ايضا الى تنقيب اثاري ربما اعتمرها الرمال
الان اكثر من مترين الى ثلاثه امتار عن
سطح الارض فلا شك انه هذه
نحاول قدر الامكان الان
نتوجه ايضا الى الجهات الحكوميه او غيرها
لمحاوله ايضا البحث والتنقيب في هذه
المنطقه لعل هناك اكتشافات رائعه جدا
ستنتج عن بعد اذنات التنقيب في هذه
المنطقه
بصراحه يا دكتور راشد اني سعيد اني اشوف
اثار باقيه في الرياض لها عشرات القرون
وش لقيتو لما نقبتو هنا او مجزته هو سوى
الاخوان بقياده الاستاذ محمد الحمود مجس
هنا في الجهه اللي خلفنا الان
واظهر فيها مجلس البسيط هذه عشره متر في
عشره متر فاظهر في جزء من هذه المنطقه
الطرز المعماريه للبيوت القديمه فكثير
الحقيقه تشاهد وتستغرب كيفيه
كيفيه البيوت القديمه مدى اتساعها او ضيقه
فوجدنا تقريبا مترين في مترين كثير من
البيوت والغرف القديمه بهذا الحجم هذا حجم
بسيط يا احد البيوت المشاهده اللي عمل
عليها المجلس فلا شك الحقيقه تنقيب الكبير
والضخم في هذه المنطقه مستقبلا وهذا ما
نتمناه ويتمناه ايضا مهتمين لنكشف ايضا
حلقات مفقوده يقدم لنا للجميع بيحاولة
التنقيب في هذه المنطقه كلها من الحجره لا
شكلها من حجر وايضا تصميمات مختلفه في هذه
المنطقه العوامل ايضا مساعده لوجود ايضا
الحياه والنماء في هذه المنطقه عشرات
السنين وهذا ما حصل ايضا هذه الجهه وشوفهم
بانين فوق ضفه وادي حنيفه يعني مهما اتسع
الوادي او صار في فيضان تلك القرون
الماضيه يعني يعني
قاسوا الجوانب البيئيه الجوانب البيئيه
وايضا الجوانب الامنيه يعني اغلب المدن او
البلدات اللي على امتداد وادي حنيفه يعد
العامل الرئيسي الاول اللي هو قضيه الامن
وايضا تامين المنطقه عن جريان الوادي
ولهذا نجد في وادي حنيفه بعض البلدات
والقرى اندمرت به ايضا مراحل زمنيه طويله
بسبب جريان السيول عليها لكن هذه المنطقه
حافظ عليها بسبب ارتفاعها عن سطح الارض
نعم جميل والمجس هنا في هذا النعم في هذه
الجهه خلفنا الان هذه اللي عمل فيها وتبين
حقيقه اثار رائعه الحقيقه لان المزيد
والجديد اذا تم اكتشاف هذه المنطقه او
عمليه البحث فيها
اتون من الحجاز وغيرها عبر طريق ابا القد
المعروف بالجديه وصلت قبائل عربيه ومنها
بنو حنيفه الى قارات الحبل فكانت الخطوات
الاولى للوصول والاستقرار فيما بعد في قلب
حجر اليمامه كان ذلك قبل نحو
1600 عام بقياده عبيد بن ثعلبه زعيم قبيله
بني حنيفه هو الذي انتقل بقبيلته من
الترحل الى الاستقرار في وادي العرض بمرور
الايام استبدل الوادي اسمه القديم ليكون
مراه لاهله فاصبح كما يعرف
وادي حنيفه نحن الان في قارات الحبل جمع
قاره هو الحب المعروف ما تنبته السمره
والطلحه والسياله
والسلمه زي اللوبيا طيب هذه القارات شمال
الرياض الان طريق الملك سلمان يخترقها هي
من الحجر الجيري دوائر صغيره منتشره
وسيد بني حنيفه منين جاء وليش اول ما نزل
نزل قارات الحبل قبل ما ينحدر جنوبا الى
حجر اليمامه وياخذ الحدائق المتبقيه من
طسم وجديس هو لابد في النطاق الجغرافي عند
النزول من ايضا الحجاز بني حنيفه لانهم
نزحوا من الحجاز
ونزحوا لعوامل مختلفه لكن المؤرخون يشيرون
الى يتبع مواقع القطر يعني في ازمه حصلت
في تهامه عشان نقول هم جابني حنيفه جو من
المدينه ولجوا من مكه ولا من تهامه جبال
الحجاب
فانا الانتقالهم هنا ووصلوا ايضا الى
الجديه وبيعدم ومن الجديه ايضا اتجاههم
هنا الى الشرق واي الملجا ثم نزحوا ايضا
والى هذه المنطقه الواسعه المسماه بقارات
الحبى العباره عباره عن قاره هذا الجبل
الماثل امامنا احد ايضا القارات الموجوده
ولهذا كانت
كان هنا النزول واستقرار اياما متعدده ثم
نزوعهم الى حجر اليمامه واستقرارهم هنا
ولهذا كان ابعد نقطه مكانيه بين حجر
اليمامه وبين قارات الحبل في الناحيه
المكانيه ولهذا يقول الشاعر القديم من بني
حنيفه او الذي سكن في حجر اليمامه يقول ما
ابالي الايم سبني امع والذئب بقارات الحبل
هنا الذئب تعوي الذئاب هنا لانها بعيده عن
المكان الاصلي في حجر اليمامه فهناك
المسافه الشاسعه قربت العشرين كيلا الان
اصبحت المسافه قريبه بين حجر اليمامه
وقارات الحبل فتلاحمت وتلاقيت ايضا هذا
المكانين المعروفين والذين كان لهم من
الاهميه في تاريخ الرياضه
اذا قارات الحبل نزلوا هنا عبيد بن ثعلبه
الحنفي اكيد كان معهم خيام ما بناوا ولا
وكان في موارد مياه قديمه صحيح لكن لما
راح الراعي جنوبا واكتشف في قصور في حجر
اليمامه وحصون نزل ولهذا
الابار القديمه وايضا بعض الشعبان القديمه
تاتي هنا من الجهه الشرقيه في المطار
القديم والمطار القديم حتى عباره عن اثار
قديمه تعود الى 20 الف سنه في المنطقه
كلها ملعه ايضا بالاثار القديمه وايضا
تعود الى الاف السنين طيب خلنا ننحدر الان
جنوبا الحجر اليمامه من قارات الحفر نمشي
على نفس الخطا اللي مشى عليها عبيد بن
ثعلبه الحنب
[موسيقى]